der stein sie sind uns aufgefallen sie
sind uns aufgefallen weil sie eine
begegnung im supermarkt hatte 36
explosion das klingt für viele noch
völlig abstrakt jeder sagt ja ja das ist
dann irgendwann ein problem vom herbst
vom winter irgendwann kommt das auf uns
zu aber uns geht es doch noch gut sie
habe sie wissen nein das ist noch lange
nicht so es geht ganz vielen menschen
richtig schlecht erzählen sie das was
sie interessiert ist ein supermann also
man sieht natürlich einkaufen und man
kauft ein natürlich stellen wir fest
dass kilo preise oder stückweise teurer
werden aber solange man das selber immer
noch tragen kann dann drückt man das weg
ja man hört natürlich immer die
inflation wird immer schlimmer aber es
gibt ja nur noch schon 14 millionen
menschen wird der menschen in unserem
land besonders ältere menschen und
kinder die schon stark und der armut
leiden und jetzt kommen noch diese
explodierenden preise dazu und dann
miteinander kasse steht man sich die
menschen um sich herum und dann ist noch
eine person davor und dann sehen sie
eine alte dame bezahlen ja zwischen 70
und 80 und sie stellen aber fest wie sie
halt nicht
bezahlen kann wie sie nach ihrem kein
geld wird und das hatte ich mehr hat und
sagt dann auf was können sie was sie
verzichten hat und sie geht das brot und
bringt mal auf schnitt zurück auf jeden
fall fehler dass wir in ein paar tagen
und das dann sieht man das kino an damit
ich mache der verkäuferin vorwirft ich
meine alles andere ist das verschenken
würde der diebstahl ja aber man sieht
dass du dann sehen sie die alte dame
weglaufen und sie sehen also diese
schmerzt den man da führt und dann gehst
du dahin und bezahlst deine sachen und
siehst du kannst das alles noch bezahlen
wie damals frage du kannst es ich habe
dann dieses brot und hinaus schnell
mitgenommen und in der alten dame
nachgegangen sie erst mal erschrocken
hat als ich sehr angesprochen habe ein
großer kräftiger spricht sie an und dann
sagen wir das tun sie mir in dem fall
nehmen sie das bitte mit leben sieht und
dann sehen sie einerseits diese diese
freude und dann die tränen und sie sehen
eine alte dame die anfängt zu weinen und
sofort ihr herz ausschüttet und in ein
paar worten schon alleine sagt dass sie
nicht mehr leben der stelle nicht mehr
erleben möchte weil sie nicht mehr weiß
wo das hirn geht hier in unserem land
und nicht mehr weiß wie sie strom
rechner gas nicht nur bezahlen soll und
das macht etwas mit mir ich sehe seit
über neun jahren so viel leid so viel
schmerz so viel tod missbraucht fast
100.000 e mails bekommen von menschen
die verzweifelt sind und jetzt nicht nur
dadurch schon vorfeld bitte macht da war
two da warte ich kann ja nur schon nur
im landtag sprechen abgeordnete häuser
und der bundestag aber wissen sie ich
hatte hier für unsere politik hat
vollkommen die bodenhaftung verloren hat
vollkommen den überblick verloren und ja
wir können alle weniger duschen aber
fakt ist vorbilder zu sein bedeutet auch
vorbildlich verhalten wenn ihr opfer und
entbehrungen von menschen unser land
fordert dann müsst ihr bei euch anfang
denn eines nicht vergessen die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar und das gilt
nicht nur für reiche menschen sondern
für jeden bürger in unserem land die
politik hier am tisch sitzen und ich
will das eigentlich direkt mal
weitergeben hat die politik sehe da ist
richtig emotionen hier drinnen weil er
scheint es jeden tag mit menschen zu tun
hat die dame ist nur ein beispiel
die sich ihr leben nicht leisten können
wir der jetzt um die existenz geht weist
die politik das wir berichten über teuer
schaut gipfel wo nichts warum kommt
besprechen sie das im kabinett natürlich
reichlich bin kein teil des kabinetts
ich bin ja abgeordnete in deutschland
ihre dann aber wir sind mit an der
bundesregierung beteiligt da sind wir
sehr froh darüber natürlich wird darüber
gesprochen und das ist ein großes
problem was wir im moment haben und das
hat sich verschärft durch den
angriffskrieg den russland auf die
ukraine führt weil dadurch die inflation
einfach in einem art und weise
zugenommen hat was die leute betrifft
und da wurde schon viel getan aber dass
ihnen das nicht reicht das kann ich auch
verstehen aber klar ist auch wir haben
viele viele entlastungspaket schon
geschnürtes zweiter ist jetzt auf dem
weg in der umsetzung es gibt es gibt
einmalzahlungen auch 300 euro für jeden
bürger der dem erwerbsleben steht es
gibt ja den tank rabatt es gibt auch der
stark kritisiert wurde aber der wirkte
es ist diese energie steuersenkung die
tatsächlich auch ankommt es gibt das
neuen euro ticket was ihr alles
entlastungen sind in der summe aber ich
verstehe dass sie wenn man solche dinge
erlebt dass sie sagen das reicht nicht
und die frage ist tatsächlich was kann
man was kann man tun und wir sind auch
in der lage dass der bundeshaushalt in
einer situation ist nach zwei jahren
pandemie wir kommen aus einer zeit
heraus die schon schwierig war und sind
in eine noch schwierigere zeit gegangen
das nicht geht es nicht alles kann
kompensiert werden aber natürlich müssen
wir jetzt weiter überlegen was kann auch
in zukunft getan werden wir warten jetzt
auf den progressionsvorbehalt
das tatsächlich die bürger die arbeiten
gehen mehr von ihrem geld haben dass man
auch an den steuertarifen klett
vielleicht was macht das die leute auch
mehr geld in der tasche haben das sind
alles maßnahmen die ergriffen werden der
vorwurf politik tut der kann ich so
pauschal nicht stehen lassen dass es
immer noch mehr sein kann das kann ich
verstehen aber es kann auch nicht alles
kompensiert werden an der stelle aber
können wir also erst mal 300 euro und
jeder noch versteuert sind 260 euro
ankommen ja haben sie sich mal
ausgerechnet was man beim einkauf jetzt
mehr bezahlen
25 bis 30 prozent wie lange sollte das
reichen ein monat und jetzt gehen sie
von menschen die arbeiten was man denn
bei einer alten dame die 850 euro rente
bekommt und ein bundestagsabgeordneter
also sie inklusive ist dass sich
verstand hat hat einen rentenanspruch
von 250 euro für jedes jahr das heißt
sie sind da viel drin ob sie wieder
gewinnen oder nicht aber kommen 1000
euro rente wie erkläre ich dass den
menschen wie erkläre ich dass den alten
menschen die nicht mehr leben wollen die
nicht mal 1000 euro haben ihr leben lang
geschuftet haben für dieses land
aufgebaut haben indem sie ich unsere
füße bewegen wie erkläre ich diesen
menschen die wollen sie diesen menschen
erklären dass das gerechtfertig ist wie
wollen wir erklären dass die
bundestagsabgeordneten und ganz
besonders die führenden politiker unser
land sich die diäten erhöhen in einer
krise noch nie dagewesenen ausmaß wie
wollen wir das erklären und sagen ja das
gehaltsanpassung wo alle weniger
bekommen wo alle preise vision dagegen
wisst ihr fahren bitte und das ist jetzt
nicht persönlich wenn ihr vorbilder sein
wollt dann habt ihr bei euch anzufangen
tja wir helfen überall aber ihr habt
einen eid geschworen ich sie die anderen
sie da gemacht haben wir haben ein
einzel schon auf dieses land wird auf
diese bürger und diesen iphone
millionenfach unterstützt ein für die
bürger hier es ist noch viel mehr zu tun
schauen wir drum herum andere länder
können auch noch viel mehr tun ich kann
es nicht mehr hören hier
nicht alleine den pfosten auch wenn sie
die einzige nation in die werra niemand
gern auch und will noch mal so ein
bisschen versuchen zu entkräften das hat
man ja immer wieder fand man bei euch an
und dann geht damit ist ja eh de facto
die welt mit gerettet damit ist ja der
haushalt nicht gerettet an der stelle
und damit ist ja auch nicht alles
kompensiert was sie zu recht adressieren
und die frage die man mir stellen das
ist ihr genug ich kann mir sagen
bundestagsabgeordnete die sinne zu faul
für wie viele denken wir sind auch von
morgens bis abends unterwegs war jetzt
in sitzungswochen
ich will das auch nennen wir sind
unterschiedlicher politischer ansicht
und wir sind gewählt werden eine zeit
lang politik für dieses land zu machen
und ich spreche da für mich ich tue das
auch in voller demut und auch in vollem
bewusstsein darüber was gerade draußen
los ist ich bin aus der landwirtschaft
ich weiß was draußen los ist es gibt da
unglaubliche defizite und das ist ja
auch das was menschen wie mich ins
parlament treibt überhaupt dazu treibt
politik zu werden und sie können mir
glauben da wird auch viel getan und es
gibt mir halt oft und das ist ja das was
das macht mich manchmal auch unzufrieden
dass manchmal prozesse sehr sehr lange
nicht allen frust auf der politik
abladen die ist von einer zentralen
bedeutung und solche beispiele zerreißen
einen natürlich das erz das muss man
ganz klar sagen wir sind ja auch und
draußen im lande unterwegs wir sprechen
mit leuten und was die politik einfach
häufig vergisst ist die in dieser
abstrakten sprache wie konkret der
lebensalter für die für die menschen ist
ab 80.000 euro jahres abkommen gehört
man zu den 20 reichsten prozent in
diesem jahr das heißt man muss sich
einfach klarmachen mein sohn als
bürokaufmann verkommt geht mit 1800
brutto nach hause da gehen die abzüge
von ab da geht die miete von ab dann
bleibt der rest zum essen da ist jetzt
aber nicht viel spielraum und so geht's
verkäuferinnen so geht es leuten die in
teilzeit arbeiten aus welchen gründen
auch immer und die pyramide ist nach
unten breit und sie ist da tatsächlich
in weiten strecken arm da kann man auch
mit steuersenkungen nicht mehr viel
machen weil die oftmals schon gar keine
steuern zahlen das ist einfach ein
problem und hinzu kommt dann noch wir
haben einen ausgetüftelten sozialstaat
dass du dann schreiben bekommen es die
schlichtweg nicht mehr verstehe ist also
das ist keine arroganz dass man dann
sagt ja ich las den brief liegen sondern
du kriegst da manchmal schreiben sind
sie mittelbar oder unmittelbar
zulageberechtigt unterdessen davor sich
über das was bin ich wer bin ich und
dann lässt es lieber liegen
und immer hätte man hätte er anspruch
auf unterstützung also es ist man es tut
wirklich gut daran auch als als
politiker sich da immer mit der basis
zurück zu koppeln das kann man nicht
pauschal irgendwo machen die
diätenerhöhung sind ja auch an die
reallohnentwicklung gekoppelt also nicht
ganz ohne rückbindung zur welt da
draußen trotzdem immer raus gehen immer
mal am wochenende selbst einkaufen
und sich dem wirklichen alltag aussetzen
das kann man eigentlich jedem nur raten
natürlich und styling passiert ist wenig
was ist ihr lösungsvorschlag
gelegen also ich finde das ja schon mal
erst mal gut dass wir so meinen einstieg
das erst mal viele politiker die
führende ämter annehmen erstens schon
mal aus diesem bereich kommen das wäre
sehr hilfreich und zweitens vielleicht
auch in ihr leben schon mal gearbeitet
haben und nicht direkt zum studium in
die politik fallen weil dann ist man ein
bisschen weltfremd und wenn mir ein
kanzler erzählt der heute kanzler ist
dass er nicht mal weiß was sein wenn was
sprit kostet ja dann ist er so weit weg
von jeglicher realität dass es einfach
weh tut und ich bin sehr bürgernah er
kommt von ganz unten und ich werde dich
nie vergessen wo ich herkomme aber ein
politiker nicht alle es gibt nicht die
politik es gibt aber einige die sind
wirklich für weltfremd haben ja gar
nicht diesen diese kopplung zu den
normalen bürgern und dann würde ich da
haben sich richtig schön gesagt mein
bisschen demut mir wünschen ein bisschen
bürgernähe dass sie sich mal hinstellen
und einfach sich informieren was kostet
denn ein laib brot jetzt damit zu
verstehen und wenn ich dann sehe ich
kenne auch vor ernst also familie scholz
und frau ernsthaft fast 50.000 euro im
monat also sie wollen jetzt mal ganz
konkret politiker seien weniger
verdienen so verstehe ich sie auch
abgeordneter wir können von mir aus auch
mehr verdienen erhalten muss das geld
was sie da bekommen auch wirklich wert
sein und bitte den bürger mit
einbeziehen und nicht zu vergessen wir
machen keine wir machen politik für alle
menschen und nicht für ein paar wenige
das trifft doch hier nicht die
milliardäre die millionäre man die er
jedem doch auf ihre geschäfte die kosten
mit hochdrehzahl weiterhin mut sondern
dieses 14 millionen tendenz mehr wenn
wir diesen weg weiterhin aufnehmen wir
jetzt gehen und wer wirklich jetzt der
preiserhöhung von 67 89 prozent bei gas
und strom haben ja wie viel arbeit wie
viel armut wollen wir haben wie für
menschen tiere wohnen
auch kein politiker haben
singen sollten ja ich will sie auch
einmal finden sie dort aber zu dem thema
geht ihnen das auch so können sie diese
wut verstehen merken sie in ihrem
umkreis das erste menschen sich in ihrem
umfeld wirklich in der armut befinden
dass ich was verändert gerade aktiv ist
definitiv so und ich glaube halt das
geld ist ja da das ist ja schlimmer das
geld ist da es wird falsch ausgegeben es
wird in irgendwelche sachen investiert
die
irgendwelche brücken irgendwelche blöden
projekte oder so die die keinen nutzen
haben oder wo einfach keiner mal ein
auge drauf hat weil irgendwelche
lokalpolitiker sich vielleicht
irgendwelche paläste oder irgendwelche
denkmäler bauen wollen und ich glaube
wenn man da halt ansetzt dann gibt es
auch genug finanzielle möglichkeiten
hier gezielt zu unterstützen
ich meine es gibt genug beispiele für
schwierige ist natürlich und wir haben
das bei jeder neuen regierung in letzten
letzten jahrzehnten erlebt dass das
bestehende bewahrt wird und dann nochmal
draufgesattelt wird ist das betrifft die
stellen die die ampelkoalition ich kann
sich nicht ersparen hat jetzt 9000
stellen sich obendrauf noch mal gegönnt
da fallen 3000 weg aber netto sind immer
noch 6000 mehr sind mehrere
staatssekretäre dazugekommen sind
ganz kurios das innenministerium hat die
zuständigkeit
ausgelagert und zu einem eigenen
ministerium und hat jetzt mehr
mitarbeiter als mit der bau kompetenz
und das bauministerium jetzt solitär hat
nochmal 422 stellen sich dazu gewünscht
weil man ja alles neu regeln muss das
versteht natürlich draußen im land
keiner mehr das verschwindet so in den
in den fluren ist auch unerotisch und
die meisten leute haben wir nicht zeit
dass er sich da nun habe ich darüber zu
empören aber das sind natürlich so
effekte wo man sich immer sagt wieso
können wir uns hier ein neues amt für
die bearbeitung von riester-verträgen
das muss auch gelingen also daran muss
sich auch die ampelkoalition messen
lassen da bin ich fest von überzeugt
dass das auch gelingen muss tatsächlich
dass wir wieder zu einer normal grösse
zurückfinden
das war ja nur glück das ist dieses mal
mit noch weiter explodiert ist wie es
explodiert ist und das ist tatsächlich
auch das vorhaben was jetzt was er ganz
große priorität glaube ich haben muss
aber ich würde mir manchmal auch ein
bisschen mehr nebensätze vielleicht eine
berichterstattung wünschen denn wenn
über die aufbau der stellen redet dann
muss man dazu gehört zur wahrheit auch
dazu dass darstellen in der sicherheit
mit geschaffen wurden bei der
bundespolizei die ja wichtig sind da
wird ja keinen zweifel dran haben
natürlich kann man immer kritik üben
aber vielleicht auch ab und zu mal
einfach die den halbsatz dazu schieben
warum der manche dinge auch einfach nur
wenn uns interessante ist nur
halb so deutlich ist ein klares
bild haben dass er mir den haupt setzen
aber
das wird anders sein dass das in der
bundesregierung einige hundert stellen
neu geschaffen werden für die eu
ratspräsidentschaft und die bleiben dann
aber wir sind nicht mehr atmen bleiben
die stellen aber jetzt haben wir dann
zusätzliche stellen für die g7
präsidentschaft ich möchte wetten dass
die hinterher nicht gestrichen werden
sondern der wird irgendetwas gesucht und
bei der nächsten runde gibt es wiederum
personal aber ich habe hier raus gehört
zumindest ist das auf der sicht brille
dass das ein großes thema ist was auch
viele menschen interessiert also nahe
kostet geld und man fragt sich bloß der
bundestag so groß sein jetzt neigt sich
1010 ali t frage am ende des tages sind
die räume haben ja alle nur eine
bestimmte größe und wenn immer mehr
abgeordnete datum dann wollen sie den
genannten
werden die debatten ja nur länger aber
nicht unbedingt die debatte hier die
kleider nicht so lange wie lassen